yesterday we talked about the Kings
Indian defense they will be a different
opening as I mentioned so talk about
different openings every week and today
we'll talk about the goon felled defense
it's a very kind of a tricky opening and
very popular nowadays so it will be very
it's very important to know a good line
to play against it so this is my game
from 2010 against my opponent is a
grandmaster julio Becerra from my miami
and so this game is played at the u.s.
chess lake in 2010 in fact this is my
first game actually I ever played so it
was my debut game and he kind of
surprised me with the choice of the
opening because I didn't expect him to
play the groom felt he usually plays the
semi staff opening in King's Indian but
yeah he played the groom felt which came
as a little surprised sometimes when
opponent plays something really new it's
kind of surprising you but at the other
hand you know it's not very experienced
so don't don't think immediately dodo he
has prepared something really strong
again so just you know just playing
normal and you know I've played you know
maybe 20 30 games in this opening so I
mean after Bishop g5 so I was pretty
comfortable and he's still kind of still
new to this so so I played Bishop g5
this is what I recommend to play against
the grünfeld defense it's kind of
similar to the Petrossian and Smith's
love line in the Kings Indian but it's
more concrete you're in gruffudd is a
very concrete opening so you have to
really know what to play after each move
so play Bishop g5 here and immediately
you have a threat
no it's it's it's it's more like lots of
it's more like forcing ideas so let's
say if he makes a move you have to you
must make this move so it's like or you
can't just slowly develop everything so
it's a little bit like like for example
he goes ninety four so if you don't know
the right move here you could be in
trouble right away so if you're white
here what do you do see take but that if
you take it's you know it's not it's not
considered that good even though there
was a game played between magnus carlsen
against a actually saudi models image
was white against magnus carlsen and he
actually took only four but it's in a
korean theory this is not considered the
best move 9ft is well you don't want to
lose the bishop he takes your doctor
bishop in a fiance toe positions you
don't want to lose your when opponent is
doing if you actually you don't want to
lose your dark square bishop okay well
f4 it's a bit to be too risky yet bit
weakening the position so he wants to
take my bishop what do you think would
be the best move here he just played
ninety four activating this night so
question is what you're going to do now
you don't want to lose the bishop
absolutely.you retreat on h4 it's very
important not to go to f4 sandwiches to
h4 okay now you're threatening to take
the pawn on d5 so he takes pawn takes
Bishop g7 now you develop so white will
have a strong center and black is going
to try to put pressure on d4 by playing
C v g5 here very risky because after I
retreat even if you can take my bishop
but g5 really weakens the position so
it's not going to be a good idea because
your Center is also weak so it will
really weakened the position so he takes
you play III because you want to keep
this structure okay because you want to
make sure you have this pawn structure
against the bishop because this way the
dark square bishop is going to be
passive so that's why we play this move
now I played c5 putting pressure to the
center I take on doubling my double
pawns Knight f3 Knight c3 Bishop e2
castle castle if you remember I don't
know if you I've done a lecture I think
a couple of weeks ago at the club where
I showed one of my games against
international master David Bruce so it
was the same exact opening and here he
took on d4 in that game and you can also
find this video on the website but in
this game Grandmaster B salad didn't
take on d4 he played Bishop f5
and now this book gives me an
opportunity to play something different
because he didn't just take on the force
so it's a little bit different position
here so I want you to think about it now
and try to see what's the best move here
for white developing the bishop and now
controlling important squares so it's
you know he's just developing 92 is a
possible move it's a move that has been
played in this position but I didn't
play that yet later on in the game you
will see me playing 92 but not right now
right now I just want to play logical I
develop my minor pieces got the control
of the center castle so what would be
the logical next step develop the rooks
or queen first a lot of times you
develop the Queen first to connect the
rooks okay to develop say we we can't
really develop the rooks now because
rook e1 would be no very passive or okay
one we cannot move because we lose the
pawn queen is attacking it so we need to
take the Queen but where Queen a4 I
could play this move yet it's possible
but something better if you compare the
Queen's now who's queen is more active
black queen is more active right can I
somehow offer exchange of Queens that
will help me to bring more puns closer
to the center AHA Queen b3 now I am also
attacking the pawn on b7 so now it's
kind of forced to exchange the Queens so
he takes I take now if you look at the
position you can see that I have only
one pawn island which is very important
in the end game and he has two and very
important my rook is already on the open
file
so I don't have to waste move develop
this piece because this piece is already
developed so it's going to be an endgame
where I will have the control of the
Santosh
now he took and here you have to make a
decision you can capture the power back
with three different ways upon c-pawn or
with a knight which capture routing is
the best yes well we need to be more
specific because we have two pounds very
good that's what I played aha triple
chain uh-huh
yes why excellent point also if we take
with this pawn what we're going to have
here weak pawn right and that pawn is
kind of isolated alone so we don't want
to have a problem like that but also
when we take with this pawn which I did
now we have this chain and if we can
push this pawn forward we can have a
strong chain yes you could take with a
knight but it could take
it doesn't really necessarily improve
our position exchanging the night after
board in fact I think we want to leave
the Knights because when we play d5 we
attack it's night so we gain a temple
because either way I take now I have
this d5 threat he needs to worry about
so we want to keep one pair of the
Knights we don't want to it's very
important not to just liquidate in the
opening
sometimes I see players they just
whenever there is the chance they try to
liquidate you have to really realize
before you exchange things do you really
want to exchange so it's very important
not just think exchange the past
exchange the pieces you have to see
sometimes like in this position I have
space I have more control the sensor I
want to keep the Knights on the court so
I can actually chase his knight now rook
fc8 yes
well the rules are you know for any type
of game we play could be a blitz game or
yeah it's a little bit different blitz
III played lots of glitz I mean all my
life I like to play blitz but it's very
important to play in a natural moves and
basically first instinct a lot of times
in blitz that's the move that you have
to play it so most of the time that's
the right move to play but yeah that's
what I would recommend it just you know
but not who if exchange you know all the
time because you have to see when you
want to exchange when you don't so here
we want to keep one pair of the Knights
because we have this d5 threat now he
goes here so I could play ad fire but
then I gotta be a little bit careful
opening up this diagonal okay so now you
need to find a move for white
what do you think is the best move here
because I want to make sure I keep those
c3d for for now yes well we could do
that but you know our bishop is well
placed on h4 because it's putting
pressure see this putting pressure he
keeps his Knight
you know he can't just move away because
we'll take the pawn so that's why we
don't want to move the bishop yet okay
yeah yeah he could play if I but if I
have it we have d5 so if I have it's not
something we have to worry about too
much right now
yes Raquel c1 is a possible move I think
I play the different move fish because I
want to try to create a threat
yeah but but there is a there's a
problem if we go here take the night he
takes to the rook and now all pong it
pawn is hanging to and we lose the
bishop so pair of the bishop is
important see in a position like this if
you bring the bishop you want to take he
would just defend like he would maybe
play King f8 and then you don't want to
give up Bishop for a 99 game because he
will have the pair of the bishops so
what else we can try to do here
very good huh so I think I played before
let's see yes yeah I played before
that's it's a it's a very nice smooth I
really like this movement I played it
because now immediately I'm creating a
threat and that threat is B 5 ok yeah
I'm sure you see the thread right we
push the part we want to attack and win
the pawn and very important we gain
space when the pants move forward they
gain space you have to make sure you
don't weaken the position button in this
case we gain space so we have a very
nice pawn chain here on the Queen side
ok and open a file he plays a6 now this
move force them to weaken his position
but they had to do that to stop the
threat now again see I didn't just play
like kind of standard moves in this game
every move had a specific idea behind it
and I want you to try to find this idea
now again so you can just take the rook
and put it on c1 this would be kind of a
standard reply but try to see if you can
use all the options you have in this
position
we want to play d5 right but we have a
problem this pawn is always hanging look
fd1 you could play that yeah it's
possible move but there is a better idea
yes c4 be careful if you play c4 he
takes on d4 you have to make sure that
your Center is protected before you play
c4
yes absolutely
route 83 you take advantage of the fact
that you have the open file not only you
move up now you can double up the rooks
on a file now I also protect the c3 pawn
and now attracting to play d5 also
threatening let's say he just plays
ecigs rook F a1 threating b5 it's a
serious threat it's very difficult for
him to do anything now if he goes
through b8 I go Bishop g3 now it looks
like for a moment looks like Bach should
be ok I mean he's got development he's
got no weaknesses but his pieces you
know they don't have many squares to go
to so ruk a3 is a very important move
here without this move it's going to be
very hard to claim in a much advantage
here very important here my opponent I
think he didn't like his position so he
was just really desperate to create some
counter play now and he played a logical
move but I think this Moxley makes his
position perhaps even worse now I mean
but in a group where players they like
to play active they like to open up the
center so this is kind of a natural idea
now he plays a5 trying to break the
center and here my response it's pretty
much the only thing I can try to do here
I can't take only 5 I can't let them
take on d4 because that will just really
make my position very bad so b5
attacking the knight Knight doesn't have
many squares you can go to so it cannot
go to e7 I will take knight on b8 will
be very passive so you played 98
retreating and now getting ready to play
efore attacking the knight and on c3
now what I think is the best proof here
you have to try to see which squares are
weak for the opponent first you find a
weak squares and think about it which
piece you want to put on the weak square
which square is the weakest square in
this position for black these six is a
weak square there is another square I
think little even weaker than that b6
uh-huh can you imagine we put a knight
on B 6 that will be great not so we got
d6 we got b6 okay see you don't want to
rush here and think oh I have to push c4
c5 no need to rush here first try to see
a piece that you can try to improve we
could go okay one but I don't want to
commit yet this rook here and plus he
wants to push a four so I want to make a
move that will lead me to this idea of
putting the knight to be six yes
absolutely
92 not only this move is a very strong
position or move when I realize I have
this move I kind of felt like I it's
it's pretty much over here because he
can't just he can't really do anything
here it's kind of it may sound a bit
strange but I think this position is
almost lost now for him because he can't
even play ninety seven why do you see
the problem with this normal developing
move
just after that democracy 40 can't stop
police upon
well because these blocking to be six
squares yeah there's something else you
can try to do look carefully what can
you do here we don't really think say
like we're we're too focused perhaps on
a queen side but what we have on the
other side of the board you always have
to make sure you're observing the entire
board you can just focus on one side of
the port because you might have a great
move but it's on the other side of the
board okay G for now let's try to find a
good square for the bishop not going to
be easy that's why I said I felt like my
advantage is really big here you know
even though we just kind of got out of
the opening no good squares to go to
except here and if it goes here now what
do we do to win this bishop
perfect they should be strapped
sometimes you could have really like a
positional big advantage it's not like
material advantage but positionally so
this is one of these positions so he
can't go 97 so he tries to play Bishop
h6 activating his bishop yes yeah I
always look I always looked a few moves
ahead always but I mean when I played 92
I realized by 9 he was going to d6 or d6
and he can't go 97 you know longer
longer this pieces stay like this it
means his position is getting worse and
worse because I'm improving his position
his pieces are sitting there so longer I
can keep these pieces there it's just
better for me so now it was just you
know I paid 92 and I you know see this
g4 idea I have because in fact I was
thinking about g4 also it's interesting
to play g4 because you move this bishop
back to d7
if the bishop goes back to the seven
then occupies the square the knight can
go to so now is really like crumped yeah
it can do anything
yeah so so he plays Bishop age to a6
he's trying to create something now I
think the next move you you know the
next move right 94 threatening Knight b6
and 96 so he can only stop one you can
stop both threats so he goes here it's
top one but not the second one now we
come in see Bishop is doing an excellent
job also guarding this square so now
it's pieces are working excellent here
all my pieces now what should I do here
now
g4 is possible but I wasn't so sure
about you know how effective it could be
here because if I play g4 he has this
Bishop f8 move
this is not there so if you take I take
on d6 I mean you know we both losses
upon it take take or even Knight f5 yeah
but this this I have to say this looks
good also
this looks good too
oh yeah I realize he goes Bishop c2 yet
this was the problem and you know this
bishop is actually stopping rook c1 and
we cannot attack him from the side
become because then he takes so it's
kind of not so clear you know this
Bishop is looks like it's going to get
trapped but not so clear how and if I
play g5 then it goes back we should be
fate attacking my knight so see when you
have a good position you want to avoid
this complications you just want to play
solidly just improve your position now
which will will improve our position
here and we'll be logical continuation
of our plan yes b5 c5 but then it plays
a5 you weakening gets e5 square
actually you don't wanna play b5 you're
giving the excellent square for the
knight to go to you know this pawn is
doing a good job guarding this square
you don't want to move that pawn Knight
to d5 just goes back rook c8 probably we
have a repetition but exchanging a
knight we could do that but we don't
need to rush that Bishop is not going
anywhere now let's wait a little bit
we'll play a little bit later let's
improve the position first
Bishop c4 you could double of course c4
continue advancing the pants right c4 c5
you have the strong pants strong chain
is strong because you can move forward
right that's the advantage of having a
chain like this because you can push
forward one is protecting another
another one is protecting another so
it's like if I can put the ponds before
d6 c5 it's very strong protecting and
controlling squares so you guys Bishop
f8 you realize you can just let me push
again so he attacked my knight now let
him waste the temple now I take he can't
take on before because if it takes on
before I can just go rupees through b3
winning so here so take back and now
absolutely c5 and now I'm about to play
d6 well well the bishop they should take
a look so but in general even though
when if the rook is not hanging you
don't want to play b5 because if you
play b5 then you're creating dark square
weaknesses and the knight will have a
square to go to on c5 so decide we want
to play c5 now he plays efore trying to
get something at least going here with
maybe 95 idea or something now
t6 he has to go back if it goes rook c6
do you see the winning move here it's a
very nice move Bishop b5 yes attacking
the rook rook cannot go back you take
the bish night and you cannot capture
back you take the rook so he has to go
here now I could go to g3 check but he
goes King h8 I believe there are many
good continuations here so perhaps rook
g3 is very good too so it's not like
this is a position where you must play
one specifically there are many way this
is a winning position here for white so
there are many ways to play but I
decided to play rook d1 because if you
look at the position you will realize
there is only one piece that I need to
develop here right and I want to develop
this piece to d1 because I want to be
able to go rook d5 and take the pawn so
even when you improve your position you
still have to make sure that you have
all your pieces developed because you
know it's very important to get the last
piece into the game now he goes here
Bishop g7
now I'll go Bishop g5 idea behind this
one is just to control this diagonal and
when I attack you cannot really push
this pawn to f4 so this was the idea
behind this from Bishop g5 9 ghost
Bishop e5 trying to get control of some
of the dark squares and here a very
strong move you need to play
you have many different options but
which would be the best teacher yes F
for fixing the weakness the weakness is
f5 pawn so we're fixing the weakness and
of course if it takes here we're very
happy because we just take back with a
bishop and not only we get rid of his
strong pawn only for now we have a
bishop that is putting pressure and then
rook d5 and we can also take back with
the RO can take the pawn so he can take
taking is very bad so if place now is to
move the bishop means losing another
temple now I play Bishop c4 first rogue
d5 I could play I might have something I
didn't like about something I thought he
could do perhaps you could play g4 but
again in a position like this where we
have a complete control you know you
don't want to open up anything there you
just want to go Bishop c4 rook d5 rook F
5 and f7 is hanging - I think I try this
move because I also have this Bishop d5
idea I didn't think I need to go right
away
perhaps some a5 ideas you can do but the
rock d5 is a good move - now if you look
at the position it doesn't have any good
moves
Brooke d5 is coming up next and take all
the pawn on f5 so he goes 9 f6 trying to
prevent that
now what can you do
you want to win that f5 Bonilla
hmm I take he takes Rock d5 now I'm
winning their five pawn then it's Bishop
is hanging and also f7 is very weak so
he goes a5 if it doesn't do anything
then he just loses without counter play
sorry okay okay plate a5 trying to break
the chain and create some complications
like for example if you take he wants to
do a tactic takes on c5 then check the X
so you have to watch out for this
tactics here but of course when I went
for this position I expected to move a
five so I had something in mind that I
will do if he does this and that is hey
III you could do that but
you could do that but here you have a
chance to win a pawn actually not the
five point five point is already ours
because he can defend that another point
you can win here see when you have
strong pounds like the pawn on d6 if not
just there to just look good you know in
some point you have to put upon into use
right so we go to the seven now
obviously if it goes back here it's just
we can just go B 5 C 6 7 so he has to go
to C 7 and now this is a trunk it's not
very strong here right so I take with
the rook the last trunk so if it takes
now I go d8 Queen check Bishop takes
Ruby a check and then I take the rook so
he can take now here too so again let's
take a look if it takes we go check
he takes check comes up I take the rook
and white is up a piece so he could
maybe win two pawns but still lost
position so he played rook d8 now
threaten to win the pawn on this seven
and this is the part that you want to
make sure you don't lose it's very
important to keep this pawn okay
so you don't want to lose the pawn how
do you keep this pawn nine plays Bishop
c3 activating his bishop and also
attacking the pawn on b4
very important move here again
yes mm-hmm
933 trying to push the spawn to deflect
my bishop so he can take the pawn on g7
so this King you can go to f2 King f1
now you block this pawn to not allowing
any counter play my ghost King f8
blocked upon directing to take it should
be too
and now finally after it's already safe
we take the pawn white is up 2 pounds
and black cannot move anything here his
rooks cannot move anything so he decided
to sacrifice the exchange so he takes I
take if it doesn't take here I have a
few different different ways how I can
try to win in this position I can I can
move my rook away let's say go rukiye 5
and then go to create that's probably
the easiest way to win so so he has to
take now it takes so I'm up exchange and
a pawn
so this is pretty easy win here but what
would be the best way to convert this
advantage
think you don't want to just check yeah
when you have we have one I have an idea
where do I have advantage still on which
side of the board b5 right because let's
create he took out a passed pawn but
here to sacrifice the exchange it's okay
let's create another one okay because we
have two on one right we create another
passport now I was Bishop c1 trying to
get some counter play with roopd two and
you don't want to allow any contra play
because if he goes check then you cannot
take he has a discovery check on your
rope so it gets absolutely Rock a two
and looks like he after this move he
just resigned because next move is going
to be rook c2 and c6 c7 so from a first
not it's a very easy game and you
wouldn't think that my opponent was you
know strong Grandmaster 2560 feeder
rating Grandmaster basura is a very good
player but he just got played a little
bit inaccurate in the opening got into a
bad position and it was very difficult
for him to do anything in the endgame
okay so remember if somebody play's the
groom field you just play like this okay